Welcome to my new series
where I rate political party posters that I've seen in the wild
and the likelihood of I would vote for them.
Every political party starts at 50%
they can work themselves up to most likely I might vote for them
or work themselves down to least likely I would never vote for them.
So we gonna start with the Freedom Front Plus
because it was the first political party that hang up posters
in my city. That's why we starting with them
not because I believe why people should go first.
Firstly,
they are apartheid apologist and don't think apartheid was a bad thing
so minus fifty % from them don't like the colours minus another 10% um
mmm mmm mmm oh yeah
according to the I. E. C
the party is not the Freedom Front Plus
but it's the Afrikaans name
which means alphabetical order in the ballot paper.
They are literally down there.
I am not being in that booth for more than two minutes.
I am in and out. I have things to do.
I am claustrophobic.
I don't wanna stay there just looking for your name
maybe change your name to Afrikaner supremacist
and maybe you'll be like in the top end of the ballot paper
and we all know what y'all
you know represents Afrikaner supremacy.
Um and the guy looks like he would call me Bridget because my name
inconvenience is his tongue
like I would say my name Is SQINISEKO and he would say nah
I'm gonna call you Bridget
he looks like that kind of guy
he looks like he has a toupée on and then I don't like men yes
but I don't like dishonest men
so
because they are about apartheid apologists and believe apartheid was good
minus the 50 they got initially
um because I don't like the colours
minus 20 because they are so far in the ballot paper
minus another 20 because this guy looks like he can't say my name
minus thirty so what's the math?
Oh my gosh minus 20 ha ha I don't know but they in the negatives
I'll never vote for them join me next time
when I talk about another political party that I've seen
they post that in the wild.